so you've heard about your thought on
social media and you also say you hire
280 people in two years how do you build
a culture how do you make sure that the
people we bring in
have the same view as you have on social
media at vaynermedia very easy I'm the
head of HR , CEO right I spend anywhere
between two to four hours a day with
talking to employees we don't have a
head of HR still because the only way to
instill the culture for me is through
dictatorship right so I want them to
have a sense of values and listen we're
a very interesting company I tell
everybody I value how you care about the
other boys and girls in this company
more than how skilled you are and people
think I'm joking because it's a nice
thing to say but it then it doesn't get
executed it gets executed in my building
we've fired some of the most talented
people because they weren't willing to
be the culture fits that I want because
ultimately I want to do for vaynermedia
what I did with Wine Library the reason
I was able to leave Wine Library and
that 60 million dollar business is cuz
the culture was set and it didn't
collapse with me leaving and it's true
family I want to be able to continue to
do other businesses so I'm okay with not
letting it get too big or as big as it
can be upfront back to what I talked
about earlier which is I'm constantly in
marathon mode not in sprint mode so I'm
willing to leave 20 to 50 million
dollars on the table with this company
because I'm spending way more time than
I should as a CEO on HR issues because
it's gonna pay me dividends in 10 years
it's like the same old story
it's like parenting this is all like
parenting you know when you're fifteen
year old comes home hi and smashed the
car and all [ __ ] up and you grab your
spouse and say honey we've got to talk
about the kid it's over you sure talked
about the kid when the kid was five six
seven eight and you didn't give a [ __ ]
and you were going on vacations or work
too much this is about parenting you've
got to put in the work in the first ten
years to get the dividends in the back
ten years
Thank You Paris